come on come on let's go L come on let's
go come on oh I'm Tyler Conlin and these
are my kids this is alka he's 5 years
old he's a boy and then this is Luna
she's 4 years old and she's a girl
they're both Siberian huskys I had two
huskys as a kid and I just always loved
that they look like Little Wolves
they're definitely best friends they
have a really cute relationship throw
back throw back throw it back throw it
back our favorite thing to do is
something Outdoors we always try to do
something I like the outdoors and I like
the outdoors so it seemed like a perfect
match good boy there's some similarities
between you know what I do on the
football field and what these guys do
exercise wise in their daily lives you
know the endurance the cardio they kind
of run around Chase each other and
tackle each other and especially with
huskys you know they're medium to large
size dogs and they just love to run and
that's kind of one of the reasons we
picked our house too you know our
backyard feels like the Wilderness a
little bit and they love you know
chasing squirrels and rabbits they
definitely love the Wilderness come on
guys come on for them to be able to have
the activity level that they need to be
their diet is super important for their
coats for their health their joints the
life expectancy look at her good girl
they're there for you know a short time
of our lives at the end of the day you
look pretty I think it's huge to you
know feed them as healthy as possible
they've enjoyed Blue Wilderness it's
hard to get them to stop eating it all
right guys let's go we facing the wrong
way come on for me like I'm on a high
protein diet a lot of steak and chicken
and my kids right here their favorite
proteins and foods and steak and
chicken no really anybody in the tight
end room we all got dogs they could all
watch the dog so I trust him with my
Alaska would probably be running back
he's kind of got like long Galloping
strides Luna she probably play like
offensive
line anybody that's looking to get a dog
in general the most important thing is
to really make sure that your lifestyle
matches up with type of dog you're
getting if that lifestyle matches up
with yours then you know it's a perfect
fit you know they're such a big part of
our lives and so to be able to extend
that and uh you know spend as much time
with them as possible is really
important